[Music]
a true Islamic country will scrupulously
follow the directives of the Quran in
the Quran Allah mandates that the
Muslims fight against the Jews and the
Christians until they pay the gizia
which is a pole tax with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued
the Muslims of of course are exempt from
paying this tax this verse is the one
place where Allah directs Muslims
explicitly to make war against and
subjugate Jews and Christians the people
of the book who once subjugated enter
the dimma the protection of the Muslims
and become demies or protected people
the Islamic scholar iban juai says that
this verse is a command to fight the
people of the book Muslims must fight
them because they consider as lawful
carrying blood pork and so on and
because he says they do not enter Islam
he says that Scholars agree about
accepting gizia from the Jews and
Christians and adds that the maians or
zoroastrians have been added to them
going by the words of the Prophet treat
them as people of the book although
there is disagreement about accepting it
from idolators and sabians which means
that people who are considered
polytheists they have to convert or die
there is no intermediate stage of
so-called protection he specifies that
the tax is not collected from women
children or the insane and that it
signifies submission and
obedience another Islamic scholar Assa
specifies that the payment of the gizia
signifies that the non-muslims are
humble and obedient to the judgments of
Islam Audi another Islamic scholar notes
that the jizza is not taken from someone
in a state of hardship although that was
a stipulation at times honored in the
breach for example a contemporary
account of the muslim's conquest of niku
which was an EGP Gyptian town in the
640s says that it is impossible to
describe the lamentable position of the
inhabitants of this town who came to the
point of offering their children in
exchange for the enormous sums that they
had to pay each month similarly iban cir
says that the demies must be disgraced
humiliated and belittled therefore
Muslims are not allowed to honor the
people of dimma or Elevate them above
Muslims for they are miserable disgraced
and humil at the 7th Century jurist s IB
alus said I prefer that the people of
the dimma become tired by paying the
jiza since he that is Allah says until
they pay the jizya with their own hands
in a state of complete abasement from
the Quran another Islamic scholar Audi
elaborates that this verse is used as a
proof by those who say that it is taken
in a humiliating way and so the taker
sits and the Demi stands with his head
bowed
and his back bent the jiza is placed in
the balance and the taker seizes his
beard and hits his chin he adds however
that this is rejected according to anwi
who said this manner is invalid however
still another Islamic scholar zamak
Shari agreed that the gizia should be
collected with belittlement and
humiliation of the
non-muslims the imperative to subjugate
non-muslims as mandated by the Quran and
elaborated by The Pact of Umar remains
part of Islamic to this day the
Pakistani jihadist writer and activist
Sayed Abu Allah maudi a 20th century
figure states that the simple fact is
that according to Islam non-muslims have
been granted the freedom to stay outside
the Islamic fold and to cling to their
false man-made ways if they so wish that
heads off any potential contradiction
between his understanding of two verses
of the Quran the one that says that the
non-muslims must pay the jizya with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued and the other saying there is no
compulsion in religion maudi continues
by declaring that the unbelievers have
absolutely no right to seize the Reigns
of power in any part of Allah's Earth
nor to direct the collective Affairs of
human beings according to their own
misconceived doctrines for if they are
given such an opportunity corruption and
Mischief will ensue in such a situation
he says the Believers would be under an
obligation to do their utmost
to dislodge them from political power
and to make them live in subservience to
the Islamic way of
life on the basis of such teachings the
Islamic State demanded the jiza from the
Christians of mosul in Iraq when it took
the city in 2014 and it is now begun to
collect it also from the Christians
under its rule in Syria and this remains
part of Islamic law to this day for more
information about this go to this
website